everybody talks about building a brand
brand yourself you will always be able
to make money if your brain is strong
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believin I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world now I started
the one rule series because I see a lot
of top tens we do a lot of them every
single week just for you and some of the
rules come up over and over and over
again so that is the goal of this series
to find those most common rules and put
them into one video so today we're going
to learn how to build your brand joy be
excellent let excellence be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand I
never even knew what that was when
people say you're a brand I would say no
I'm just Oprah what I recognized now is
that my choice to it every way in every
example in every experience to do the
right thing and the excellent thing is
what has created the brand years ago I
did an ad for Revlon for for an ad they
were doing called unforgettable women
and what I know is that when you are
excellent you become unforgettable
people remember you you stand out we got
us of what it is you become an
unforgettable woman and that is what we
all want we want to be unforgettable and
not forgettable one of the people not
understanding about video okay what are
they not understanding about how
powerful it is for their business and
their brand and ultimately their message
to impact people it's always that same
question what's the ROI on social media
right what's the ROI now the funny thing
is your business work in service my
working service literally lives off of
social media so there's obviously an ROI
but the problem is we live in a world
where we want everything to be
measurable and there's a beautiful
Einstein code that says not everything
that counts can be counted and not
everything that you can count counts
right and we live in this world where
everything needs to be measured like oh
that video has a million views how many
cells did you get through that but it's
like life doesn't work like that there's
a load of adverts
and billboards on the street that the
biggest brands pay for that don't
convert into direct sales do you think
that coca-cola looks at the billboard
out there and goes how many people saw
that advert today and how many people
bought coke I'll go look because of that
advert they don't have that number it
doesn't exist and they're one of the
biggest brands in the world but they
still do it so social media video is
just a new billboard mm hm and the
biggest brands know that the more you
see it like I mean this is funny I saw
this thread so a big billboard outside
of my hotel that has all the Jenners and
the Kardashians wearing their Calvin's
have you seen it I saw it straightaway
this morning then I swear on Instagram
and I swear everywhere so already I've
seen in three places now I don't need
women's Calvera underwear but the point
is that I've seen it in a million places
so anyone who's not using video hasn't
understood that more people are going to
see video than anything else and noticed
that video is so much better than a
billboard you can say so much more right
so for me it's just a lack of seeing
opportunity there's a there's a great I
think this is a old tale it's not true
but but it's told that when Nike first
went to India they went there and it's
not Nike it's any any sneaker brand its
its ass nice story and when they first
went to India they saw everyone was
barefoot so the first reporter came back
and said oh there's no market there
because no one wears trainers and then
the second reporter went then he said oh
no one wears shoes and then he came back
and says we've got a huge market out
there right and it's the way you see it
that someone a sword no one wearing
shoes there's no mark here but another
presence where everyone not wearing
shoes as a marketing right and that's
what video is that you can sit here and
debate the ROI on video for as long as
you want the truth is every major brand
has invested in a front window
that may not translate to direct sales
or work or whatever it is man but it
does you think every brand should be
using video every bride should be using
video a lesson in branding whenever
trying to brand yourself or any company
if you change your brand from what it
used to be at a rig right away you can
get resistance so most people when they
get a little resistance but most people
are not fix it in and then they stop but
over time if you keep branding yourself
in the new brand then eventually it
catches on like I used to not have much
fitness stuff so when I hired you to
start putting Fitness stuff people are
like what does hold is Fitness now
eventually people just associate that
with you and they forget there was a
time when you didn't do it so that's a
good tip on branding you have to have
thick enough skin because it's kind of
like when Facebook changed every time
they changed their interface people go
nuts oh I hate this but in three months
later they can't remember though plenty
and then when you changed you a new one
they say no we like the one before but
that one before is the one they hated
because it was a change from the version
of you know one before but Mark
Zuckerberg smarter than people that's
why it just keeps changing it whatever
is better and then people eventually
like it same when Instagram changed
their logo snapchat changed their you
know people always a lot of people have
low OH meaning low openness to new
experience they automatically hate
anything new what do I worry about I
worry about brand control my brand is
huge now right and one thing I fight
with every day I want to make sure I
don't dilute the brand
I don't do anything make any major
mistakes because any mistake or hurt
your brand and so those are the things
that keep me up at night just making
sure my brand remains strong and so
that's a good message for all these
young men and women watching your show
just make sure that your brand is
everything and you will always be able
to make money if your brand is strong
even if you go bankrupt if your brand is
strong you'll be able to still make some
money Donald Trump proof that he bounced
right back but look where he is today
you know he went through that phase came
right back
because he kept a brand strong and
that's important when you're driving
down the highway and you see a coca-cola
billboard and then you see a big giant
bus in the city with the coca-cola
advertisement on it do you think
coca-cola knows where the sales are
coming from are they able to track the
sales from the billboards or the sales
from the bus or the sales from the movie
theater obviously not right they do
branding as advertising and they have a
ton of money and so they are just
shooting their brand out everywhere and
they are everywhere all the time right
omnipresence now when I first started
out with Fit Body Boot Camp and I wanted
to make this a global brand I didn't
think about how I can brand myself I
just wanted to do one thing I wanted to
sell one franchise location and when I
sold one franchise location I said I'm
gonna sell another franchise location
and then I sold a third franchise
location and the fourth that a fifth and
now we have hundreds of Fit Body Boot
Camp locations worldwide we've created a
national brand and it's become a thing
but before you can make yourself a thing
before you can make your business a
thing you got to first just focus on
direct response marketing direct
response marketing is accountable
marketing I know that it feeds the ego
to see yourself as a brand and a public
figure and but listen if you were to
just start putting your logo or your
brand all over the place
how are you gonna be able to track where
the money's coming from you're not gonna
be able to track that and if you can't
track it you can't quantify it the best
branding you can do in your business is
to make a promise and to keep a promise
when I created Fit Body Boot Camp
International my goal was to take
personal training and reduce the cost of
personal training I wanted people who
couldn't afford personal training to
work with a personal trainer at a
reduced rate so we went from one-on-one
personal training to the bootcamp style
and the whole idea there is one coach or
trainer and many clients and that
reduces the cost that each individual
person is paying I knew that there was a
problem and so I brought in a solution
whatever brand or whatever business or
idea that you have right now
I don't want you to think about branding
I want you to think about solving a
problem you go and you solve the problem
and everything else will fix itself
because you'll sell one and then two and
then three and so whether you're
building a franchise or you're building
a media marketing agency or maybe you're
just a one-off location selling cupcakes
make the best cupcakes you can on the
planet and when you do guess what
happens people talk about you if you
don't have a face for your business
you're gonna lose out because people buy
from people people trust people people
look up to people people care about
people people don't care about a logo I
work with a lot of big brands who are
trying to sell to the entrepreneur
community and one of the biggest things
that hold most of them back is there's
no face for the business that's nobody
we can look to and say that person
really understands me that person gets
me I now have loyalty towards this
business and if you don't have that then
what's gonna happen is as soon as your
competitor jobs are priced by 5 or 10
percent you're gonna lose a whole chunk
of business because there is no loyalty
there's no caring there's no affinity
towards a logo where it could be if you
had a face for your brand the face for
the company could be the CEO at the
highest level of your company but it
could also be a middle manager who just
really passionately but cares about the
audience I'm gonna share a couple of
examples for you
the first one is Richard Branson Richard
Branson is very active on his blog he's
active on Twitter he puts YouTube videos
up and here is somebody who genuinely
cares about people and when he's
tweeting out he has the usual corporate
stuff promoting the version stuff that
he's working on but he'll also stand up
for the fight on drugs and he'll stand
up to protecting languages and they'll
stand up for promoting innovation here's
someone who cares who is authentic who
spreads his message through these
mediums and as a result we care about
him and Richard Branson is not the
greatest speaker he's not the most
eloquent speaker he stutters a lot and
yet we love Him because he's genuine we
feel like he cares about us and so we
are gonna care about
and there's immense loyalty towards the
Virgin brand first thing is you want to
create a unified brand so across all
your social media accounts and your
website you want to make sure you're
unified with your vision you don't want
to have you know Steve the good-looking
TV guy as your Twitter handle and Steve
GBL a on its regret you want to have a
unified all the way through all the way
across the Yankee the same or just your
name first name and last name far away
across I'm pretty good you don't want to
make stuff up like though that you need
tie where a guy want to make it as easy
as possible people to remember you and
see you like creating a unique and
powerful website was it yeah you can't
really have a powerful brand if you
don't have a home base a place where
people can go to so you build your
accounts on Twitter and Instagram you
want to send people back to one place
send them back to a place where they can
learn more about you so if you have
multi platforms you're getting in the
way of yourself you're not getting the
waiter so you just want to direct in the
right place yeah that's gonna help you
here's what I love this I love this one
number three go against the grain yeah
there's a lot of people if you're
working in an industry you want to stand
out in that industry you want to build a
personal brand and that's unique that's
different that says something that is
different than everyone else people pay
attention to the decide you want to pay
attention to that I am a brand I say you
are a brand if you like it or not if you
know it or not know that some people are
uncomfortable with that like if you two
guys you know if envy and Charlamagne or
like Angela and Andy if you guys went to
lunches let's talk about our personal
brands he probably would vomit on each
other right because it's such a like a
sappy serving it seems so like
patronizing to think about it but there
is a best practice of like being honest
and saying all right well let me take an
honest inventory guts to the skin of
what I'm composed of and is everything
that I'm working on reflect that because
that is your personal brand new blue
came out with a product in 2000 in 1980
a product that was based on an
innovation to introduce ruble as a strap
it seems very common today but ruble in
1980 was a real courageous move it was
even the propagation people said hey on
a gold watch ruble because people didn't
know rubber comes from a tree rubber is
natural rubber is is very comfortable
it's very flexible and rubber is very
resistant and it's waterproof so finally
it's ideal for what but in those days
it's people thought it's a provocation
it's a and then P blue could not evolve
they stayed on a product and I said we
are not a product we have a message
first we have a concept and the concept
is fusion why because in 1980 when we
put gold together with rubber we created
a fusion because golden rubber never
come together they were together only
one time in life during the Big Bang
then everything was in one and then
rubber go it went away and said okay I
go now on my tree and God said ok I go
and rest in South Africa under the earth
and since then they never met till
people take them and connect them so I
said you know made a fusion and fusion
must be our message must be our
philosophy must be our religion and once
we have this religion clear and it is
named fusion then we can develop further
products that not necessarily need the
rubber anymore because fusion goes
further away than just rubber it can be
carbon it can be ceramic whatever so I
was capable to free you blue from the
product and give you blue a message and
from that message new products were born
and that was the most important element
in the revival of the brand it's to take
it away from a product concept and to
give it
message and from the brand message we're
then later born in 2005 new products do
you ever watch other people are the
vision videographers like video YouTube
channel se inspiration
if you could these videographers address
the tips could you get
I would say yes to
brand yourself over a lot of info
videos out there
I feel like it works time right now
where I said producer videographers
artists obviously all have the shot at
at building their own their own you know
as much as the the people performing the
music can touch you like if you grant
yourself the right way and properly
you can do that if you want but if he
can talk about that if you don't really
attach your name to it or normally build
your own trademark thinning no one's
ever gonna okay
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from rory mcilroy on how to build your
brand that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that I want to know
what is the biggest roadblock for you in
building your brand what's the biggest
question you were struggling with right
now put it down the comments below
hopefully believe nation will step up to
help you leave it in the comments thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
what is it that you see for yourself
what are your goals long-term as a
business you see some golfers you know
you see the likes of Arnold Palmer they
see the likes of Jack Nicklaus and you
see how they've built their brand over
the years and I think the most important
thing for an athlete is building their
brand on their performance on their
field whether it be on the golf course
or on the football pitch or the
basketball court or the tennis court or
whatever it is I think that's the number
one thing right then can't do one
without the other
exactly you know so I think that's the
most important and then you know if you
do have that performance on the field or
on the golf course I think then it's
about you know having a great team
around you and knowing what you want to
achieve and and I think a lot of it is
you know when you're satisfied you know
when are you happy you know what are you
ever going to be satisfied or you know I
think that's something that's a big
question mark for a lot of people if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it won't you believe it
you act like I have Tulsa what a wail
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access